歡迎收聽兆華與股惑仔
第1,164集
今天是2026年的8月18號
好 今天的台股終於有
一個比較明顯的回檔
幅度不大..
那回檔的話
終場收跌了548點
也就是大家在討論的
這樣算不算是一個開始
有一點點做一個腳
因為這一次
也許我們不用那麼在意
有沒有什麼一定要什麼
做腳什麼
當然以技術形態的人來說
這個事情還蠻重要的
因為有這隻腳
再上攻的話
就代表多頭形態的完成
那如果從基本面來看的話
我們一樣照常解釋
因為到了今天的話
應該是所有上市櫃
正常來說
因為有人財報沒有交出來
現在有點危機
正常來說都已經要交出來了
所以我們也可以就
不管是半年報也好
或是第二季的季報也好
來做一些全面性的基本面檢驗
因為漲到這邊休息一下常常講
你一直漲
其實大家的心會浮亂
就可能會亂追
或者是又覺得自己
可能反彈上來
明明是照紀律賣的
又賣飛了
心情又不好了
我們都可以先收拾一下
這樣的情緒
一切再回到現在
基本面上面的改變
或者是沒有改變這件事情
上來討論
我先來歡迎今天來賓
我想大家也應該猜得到是誰
來的就是我們的AI達人 蔡明翰
兆華、觀眾朋友、'聽眾朋友大家好
好 所以今天是有影片版的
那今天花一咪咪前面的
時間跟大家講一個慘案
就是上禮拜
上上禮拜我們講的 蔡明翰的
新粉絲團又被殲滅了
他又被鎖了
怎麼會這樣
因為我以前在東森的
數位媒體事業部擔任主管
我有幫蠻多人處理過類似的事
但是我必須講
蔡明翰贏了
蔡明翰現在遇到的情況
是我也沒有辦法再麻煩
因為我現在不在那部門
我也請該部門主管協助
我們沒有辦法處理
這個狀況
就是舊的、新的
他私人的
所有的粉絲專頁都被鎖了
所以請大家如果支持明翰
要看到本尊的話
請到YouTube的
財經震翰彈去找他
還有禮拜二我們的Podcast
和晚上的理財達人秀
對 應該..
簡單的架構就是我個人
覺得比較有可能的論點
就是等於是有人
檢舉我這個是假帳號
然後我有確實有被要求稽核
然後掃臉
上傳證件
證件本來就有
因為我本來有藍勾勾
所以證件本來就有
他又擔心這個是假帳
所以我就掃臉
掃完臉之後他跟我講
這個掃臉不透過
他覺得我這個是假帳
所以就被封了
那我後來覺得跟他在
那來來回回有點麻煩
我乾脆再創個新的就好
創完馬上跟大家宣導
對
然後為了要藍勾勾
我只好再上傳身份證
為了再一次驗證
然後我又很怕
未來會不會像之前一樣
被鎖了主帳
但粉絲頁還在
所以我一定要新增管理員
是
新增管理員
我就把我自己用了
三十幾年的私人帳號
那一個我有
當做管理員
帳號真的超正常
真的沒有
對 我什麼..
我真的什麼事情都沒
然後現在就一次鎖
只要看到
蔡明翰 然後就全部都是我
那比較麻煩的
這現在的申訴我不知道怎麼
重點是當你在臉書上
搜尋蔡明翰
你會看到很多
蔡明翰 而且都又是我的頭像
都還在 就是詐騙的都還在
還活著
但是本尊就一直被他
被他封鎖說我是假帳號
我現在也真的不知道該怎麼做
反正暫時會
未來會不會恢復我也不知道
那我該做的做
那我只能等
但我也可以知道
這可能要等很久的時間
是
那無論如何
我現在就暫時已經
不願意在上面多花時間
所以我們就抓回到
這個YouTube
對 當然在我YouTube那邊
我有請大家去投票
看他禮拜三或禮拜四
因為禮拜二我就要來達人秀
被我綁定了 綁定了
所以理論上禮拜二就在東森看
一定看得到重點內容
那禮拜三、禮拜四
也許可以選一天
我就常常講
禮拜五其實我已經在
趕工我禮拜天的影片
資料很多
對 所以這樣的我覺得節奏可以
但我們一開始講
就是我希望先有一天固定
當然如果每天真的
盤勢有很大的變化
我當然也可以
隨時
隨時幫忙更新一下
尤其市場恐慌的時候
我覺得都是
可以輕易解決的問題
好
我們就不細數了
因為我最近也是好
也受到一些困擾
但我們不講這個了
我們回到今天
Podcast的內容上
就記得以後就是先到
YouTube找明翰就對了
他也會加快那邊的更新速度
不會讓大家等太久
是 那今天的話
終於算是有一個回檔
當然從上禮拜五到昨天到今天
我們就呈現漲到4萬6千點
之後遇到一點點的壓力
都是極度正常的狀況
沒有任何的恐慌
一切都很正常
那因為明天是台指期的結算
也有人特別提到說
看起來也可能是今天
明天會做一些壓低結算
因為外資的空單水位
畢竟比較高
但一個比較好的現象是
是最近的台幣在升值
所以外資幾乎每天
都回頭來買台股
以整個8月份來說
截至昨天
因為今天的還要
等一下才會有資料
已經買了2,000多億的買超
這個以單月來說是很少見的
當然1-7月是大賣超了
那我們現在又進入到
所謂的三、四季
甚至現在有非常多的
機構一定是在展望明年
所以我們先從現在
我們已經可以拿到的
就是所謂第二季的
季報或是半年報的出爐
剛好明翰在
你覺得這一次的季報
有沒有讓你
覺得驚豔的、合乎預期的、驚訝的
好 我這樣講
我們先講幾個結論
我們先講到整個盤勢
給我的概念
是 可能我覺得投資人
比較有體感的
今年拆分成三塊
一個是上半年強到一個爆炸
7月大家突然很恐慌
因為修正的幅度蠻大
到8月
大家還在恐慌中發現
反彈這麼強
所以這三個體溫完全不同
但是結論
就是基本面一點改變都沒有
就是年初我就跟大家講
第一季的這個業績就好到爆炸
一、二月因為過年還不準
三月當時就提到
不可思議的數字
上市櫃營收在3月創歷史新高
居然在淡季就可以贏以前NB
手機iPhone出貨最旺的時間
這個就知道兩點
第一個就知道現在AI
的動能有多誇張
第二重點是你可以知道未來
二、三、四季都會持續走高所以
確實導致第二季的股市有
一個非常強的這個往上漲
7月修正的時候
就一直提醒大家
真的不要抓錯人
沒有任何的利空
純粹漲多
上半年漲5成的
修正一些
為什麼大家會壓力那麼大
在修正的過程當中
你一定會不斷的被
比如報紙去引導
告訴你說最近又有什麼利空
大家要小心
未來可能會怎樣 點點點..
但是事實上
我常常講
你會中間你會擔心下跌
你會壓力很大
我個人覺得
表示你沒有看數字
因為如果你有看到數字
它一直以來的
剛剛提到3月營收創高之後
後面真的是一路不斷往上衝
那季報的部分應該說從
去年開始
一直到今年的第一季
第二季也都一樣的情形
所以如果你把心思
多放在數字上
少一點心思放在股價的走勢
其實老實講
你就知道7月
其實修正也還好而已
然後
8月又會變成什麼樣的狀況
8月是
大家.. 漲得大家有點措手不及
是
總覺得第二隻腳
第二隻腳
每天都在問第二隻腳
當今天假設第二腳出現又害怕
對 我們也有聊到這個現象
沒有打腳你又覺得沒有跟上
有打腳了想又不要再來一次
是
那我就在常常講
這個也許
在今天講這個時間點
人家說有一些人說
確實今天有點壓力
有些人說還好吧
你也認同
那我會說
因為今天第一根
假設今天這三根
對 就是把我們從簡單來講
從4萬點彈到46,000點這個
你就算技術面反彈
你彈了6,000點
回檔個2,000點 1/3
其實都完全是很合理的
可是現在的問題
假設跌個2,000點
大家又受不了了
大家又想跑
所以我常常講
最後你要怎麼樣堅定你的信心
多花一點心思在這個
所謂的營收跟獲利上面
那我剛剛講就是
7月的營收整體上市櫃年增47%
沒錯
第二季 對
第二季的整體獲利年增
超過100%
107% 當然
我要憑良心講
因為去年的基期相對比較低
去年第二季
這個我們也常跟大家聊
有匯率的問題
對.. 當時匯率是很大的
我們外銷受到很大的打擊
關稅的問題
所以在拉貨上亂掉
當時確實是基期偏低
這是一點
還有很大的問題
就當時狀況比較不好的產業
其實還很多都是虧損的
對
然後
現在最導致最後把很多人虧損
導致把上市櫃的整個獲利
壓縮到很低的一個水位
那去年那些虧損的產業到今年
雖然不代表說獲利多好
但絕大部分都已經
轉虧為盈了
那所以導致這兩年有很大落差
那我剛剛講年增率超過100%
那我們也不要講年增率
最起碼第二季的獲利也在創高
所以代表著基本面
真的是強到不可思議
我這我自己的定義
應該說最起碼可能
我這個所謂的視野不夠
我最起碼看了這20年
現在這是不可思議的現象
是
那我只能跟大家講
回過頭來
這個短線的波動
不要看那麼緊張
而且我常常講的
沒有人看得懂短線
到底高點在哪裡
回過頭來今天開始
應該說漲到有點漲不動了
然後今天下跌了
當然目前已接近3天
已經上不去
在高檔震盪
就會有很多人看線型跟你講
有可能拉回
只是機率稍微高
但是有可能整理過後
又直接上去
有可能
對 都是有可能的
所以我剛剛常常重申
不要覺得自己或任何人
能夠抓準每一天的節奏
你要把時間軸稍微拉長一點
你才有那個信心看得準
那你就不會在意中間的波動
因為剛剛提到所有數字
都是支撐股市在往上的
那現在剛剛也提到
在我們.. 就之前7月在跌的時候
我就常跟大家講
其實7月就是技術面修正
如果可以
只要有資金 買在7月
一定是相對比較有利的
當然我常常講
那個時間點所有人都要往外衝
你一個人要往裡面走
我覺得這個真的要有一個
心理很強的這個信念才有辦法
就算沒有也沒關係
8月反彈其實也是
一個很好的一個時間點
因為下半年
應該說到第四季
整個基本面還在持續創高
這個架構短短時間
來講是不可能改變
那另外
這個就跟大家提到
我就包含當時7月在修正
我給大家一個信念
就是有一個很重要的關鍵點
我之前也提到
股市會提早半年去反映基本面
那如果這個時間點
你覺得很危險
你要必須認同一件事情
就是AI的明年不會高於今年
就是今年是一個最高點
因為你會
你可以提到說下半年好
我我剛剛講
現在從台積電角度可以
知道下半年一定會更高
你當然會可以跟我講說
那個東西可能已經
反映在股市當中了
今年上半年在漲
就是知道下半年很好
都已經反映了
所以你會有點害怕
那我.. 對 你這個是講得很有道理
股市會反映提早半年
所以你現在7月、8月很有可能
把今年好的都已經反映完
但是如果你會害怕
你覺得要下車
那你必須認同我說的
就是你覺得
明年的AI不會再成長
今年就是一個高點出現
那如果這樣
那就真的該走
因為代表的未來可能股市
會有很大的一個波段修正
可是無論如何
最起碼我會覺得
從現在你從研調單位
或者是所謂內外資券商
最起碼沒有人有這個論點說
明年的AI不可能再上去
他會所有人講的
說法只會這種AI泡沫
所謂AI泡沫就覺得漲太快了
風險是有點偏高的
但是每一次
只要技術面修正之後
回到合理水位
最後整理之後
又會再度回到多頭
所以我覺得這幾天再來
會不會出現
這個所謂的技術面修正
打第二隻腳
而尤其是我覺得最近
各自有稍微呈現脫鉤
我所謂的各自就是
台股、韓國股市、費半指數、日本
這四個就是上半年漲比較多
然後7月修正壓力很大
然後8月大家又各自反彈
但是我們是
所有市場裡面最強的
然後就是跌的
而且我們是距離歷史
高點最近的一個市場
所以我覺得說
目前來講會導致一個現象
昨天的費半指數是上漲的
但今天台股反而開高走低
是 會有出現脫鉤
那人家會說為什麼他們昨天漲
我們今天是跌的
我只能說
在8月的反彈過程當中
美股修正
我們也沒修正
所以這段時間
可能我們差不多了
會稍微壓回
但趨勢不變
所以這幾天也許會有
稍微獲利了結賣壓
來自兩個
一個是人家
當時殺到4萬點敢買的
另外一個是之前
下跌的時候
人家沒有跟著砍下去
然後一直每天都想著
反彈要減碼反彈要減碼
來到上面
上不去了
他還在考慮說
會不會就我們講的
整理個兩、三天之後再突破
那現在整理了兩、三天
出現黑K了
就可以知道
這個不用再等的
所以這幾天
賣壓一定會比較大
但是我要常講到底會幾天
只能說因為技術面
已經不可能再轉空了
所以拉回可能會有
但我覺得空間也許不會太大
最重要的過程你也
不用去猜到底有多大
你只要有那個信念
就我剛剛提到
現在第二季的財報
好到不可思議
7月的營收也很亮眼
下半年也都還在
上半年的軌道之上
所以即使技術面的修正
反而是很好的投資機會
好 我們做財經
不免是要做預測
例如說我們要去看
大家的資本支出
看看已經實現的財報
跟未來的預估財報
我們難免要去預估
就像各大金融機構也要去講
可能明年預估的點數
明年上市櫃公司
到底整體成長多少
在這個預估中
它是一個中長線的方向
這個方向目前看起來
沒有任何改變
但是你要說什麼
幾天內會怎麼改變
這個誰都說不準
誰都說不準
幾天內的現象都是說叫做正常
就算到了9月
也許聯準會那邊有什麼事
我們現在也不確定
美議也還沒打完
但都不是新的黑天鵝的話
再遇到一個修正
我想大家還是要保持著
我們到第四季到明年全年
因為現在的局勢其實算明朗
怎麼講
資本支出這件事情
在最新一次的各個產業的
當然8月24號還有輝達財報了
他們提供出來的都是明年
看起來會比今年還要多
所以都在上修所謂的資本支出
不管他上修的時候
當下股市怎麼解讀
氣氛不好的時候覺得你亂花錢
氣氛好的時候
覺得明年欣欣向榮
但是明年要多砸錢這個
事情目前是非常確定的
那現在企業去開法說會
講下半年
其實市場很現實
如果講說下半年比較持平
成長比較緩的
通常股價就會先給你來一根
可是如果大家講得很樂觀的
記憶體是一個
比較特別的族群了
等下再另外拉出來說
如果講得比較樂觀的
就算你今天第二季的
財報不一定非常好
市場還是給你掌聲
拍拍拍 好
所以我覺得現在的局勢
叫做明朗
那在明朗的情況中
定心就是假設之後
不代表說
都不會跌了
就跟明翰剛剛講的
如果又出現一個2,000點的跌點
您的心情是什麼
以我來說
我非常喜歡
在大跌的時候做加碼
所以像今天我就小加碼
我在這樣的局勢裡面加碼
我的心情是比較舒坦的
那剛剛講到第二季的
這個營收年增率
因為去年的基期低
我這邊這個
應該是偷了明翰的圖
就是上市櫃企業的獲利
年增率是到了173.9
好那當然分開來的話
電子 電子通路
電子零組件是裡面的大主流
是 都是100-300%的一個年增幅
但是也可以看到
像鋼鐵去年都在虧
那現在年增幅
就千位數的年增幅
對
代表今年第二季其實
有很多的傳統產業
在去年慘兮兮 被關稅打爛
被這個匯率打爛的
現在也可能叫做虧轉盈
所以像現在盤面上
前陣子不是鋼鐵有動嗎
然後塑化是因為轉成電子化
也有動
像這兩天什麼貨櫃航運
散裝航運
等於是說傳產其實也有在
反映今年下半年會比去年
下半年好很多的這件事情
這些都是蠻支持台股的
一個底氣
那既然在這樣的前提下
我們就要知道自己
喜歡的東西是什麼
因為不可能1,700檔你都買對
所以如果再遇到
你喜歡的買法
有人喜歡的買法是
確立漲勢的追上去
有人的喜歡買法可能跟我一樣
就是我確立基本面沒問題
跌下來了我再加
那我不像明翰那一種
明翰就是高持股不下車
有信心
對 因為很簡單
我自己覺得
我自己的定義就是
我自己看不懂
結論就是我短線我看不懂
所以我很..
我老實說我很容易賣飛
所以我經過幾次教訓 我就懶
因為我就覺得反正抱著下去
人家講你會抱上又抱下
是
那我會覺得抱上又抱下
這個東西比較
應該這樣講
我覺得抱上跟抱下比較
適合在2023年沒有AI以前
是 指數一直在1萬點附近震盪
震盪
所以你抱了N年的上上下下
沒錯 最後都回到原點
你只賺股利
最後賺不到什麼錢
那是沒錯
可是這幾年你
抱上又抱下是中間的小幅震盪
但是長線卻能夠持續走高
那很大的問題
就是中間震盪很大
但是趨勢還是維持多頭
那你在減碼的過程當中
我常講的
不是不能講
我講的是我自己
我常常講
這是我自己的問題
因為我有點懶
然後我不想花很多
的時間在交易上面
這是我自己的問題
我先跟大家講正確的
方法應該要怎樣
我不要講我的方..
我講正確 應該的方法
應該是說
你可不可以減碼
當然是一定可以
可是我覺得
有一個很重要的關鍵點
就是你要記得一件事情
這我剛剛最早提到
這市場上沒有人
看得懂短線的波動
包含你自己
所以當你覺得
應該在這裡差不多
應該要減碼的時候
有一個我覺得投資人
通常比較欠缺的問題
就是你要設一個你錯了
要怎麼辦的問題
是
我覺得大部分的人
就缺少這個問題
你要有個策略
就是說你今天漲到100塊
你覺得夠了
那你一開始你要
你覺得要出場
第一件事情你先告訴你自己
你今天出場
你就純粹覺得
趨勢沒有轉變
只是你覺得在這裡
你想賺一點價差
那你這個時間點要出場
你一定要 兩個事件你要先定好
第一個就是你拉回來多少
你要撿回來
這個是很基本
比如說你
我100塊賣
我90塊 回到90塊我就是
我就一定把它買回來
這第一件事情
第二件事情就是
萬一不是你所想的
最後100塊就沒回來
就上去了
那我就會說
那沒關係
過105塊我就認賠 再追回
那你只要這兩點做好
你就可以去做一些
稍微減碼的操作
我覺得沒有問題
那只是因為我就說常常講
我工作很忙
我白天雖然我是投資
但我其實盯盤的時間
實際上真的不多
那我要做很多的工作
所以我很難說先出一點
然後等一下有跌了
我再買回來
所以通常我就會覺得
放給他去
然後反正長線
那個中間的波動
我就裝作沒看到
反正長線而言
我是對長線非常有信心的
那我也覺得我賣掉之後
我不見得有辦法賺到那個價差
最後
我覺得我現在100塊賣掉
我90塊
我不見得
應該這樣
或有可能沒來90塊
有可能來90塊我也在忙
我也沒時間再去照顧他
那最後
我到105塊我反而都要追回
長期而言
我想賺下面的10塊
不見得賺得到
但我可能常常反而
漏失的是上面那5塊
我每一次最後反而賣掉
之後又要再高價追回
但是所以我最後我就
乾脆什麼事情都不做
反正結論長線我就不動
短線的就是
還是按照自己的節奏
可能看到什麼強勢你想做就做
然後這個就跟大盤可能
沒有太直接的關係
所以我永遠就是
長線、短線是分開的
你短線你可以做自己現在覺得
強勢的個股
甚至你基本面都不用了解
你可以看籌碼面
你可以看技術面
各樣的條件都可以
只要符合你的條件
你就可以短線操作
只是短線的
通常只要
一發生風吹草動
第一個事情就是把
先把短線都先出掉
那長線的部分來講
相對來講就怕
比較不怕震盪
所以常常講就是長短線要分開
那我又在講的
就是我常常說的
就是投資人
你如果有個我以前都會講3年
或我覺得有點久
我個人覺得
有一年甚至有半年以上的
投資經驗
你就應該要稍微長線
短線稍微做一點區隔出來
比較不適合
所有的資金都是短線
哪怕你只用一、兩成
買在長線也沒關係
但你一定要放一些
你的資金在長線
因為我以前
等於說我這20年
我幾乎前十年
也是完全沒有長線
因為我覺得我們在法人
我每天訊息這麼多
我有這麼多的資源
我就贏人家
自己覺得
雖然事後發現完全沒有
完全沒有任何優勢
因為為什麼這樣
對 我訊息很多
這問題是每天的
投資人可能沒有訊息
我有100個訊息
問題是訊息有對有錯
你根本沒有辦法當下判斷
所以只是增加你的交易頻繁度
但最後也不見得
真的多賺到多少錢
我最後常常
當然有賺錢沒錯
但我覺得長期沒辦法累積到
比較大的這個財富
所以後續就慢慢的
這個真的經過多年的移動
然後後來稍微有點資產在長線
然後慢慢發現我短線很忙
但是賺的錢也不見得
當然絕對金額因為短線比較大
所以絕對金額也許比較多
但你會發現報酬率長線的
好像不見得比我的短線差
所以自然就慢慢多
移動到這個所謂的長線
但是確實
我在2020年
應該說
台積電的獲利
還沒有明顯動起來
AI還沒有成型之前
我的長線的比例真的是
明顯的小很多
絕大部分還是以短線為主
那後來經過疫情
然後那個時間點剛好重挫
我就把
很多的短線拿去押在長線
然後後來就在賺那個
疫情結束的那個那個財富
然後等到覺得
差不多要下車的時候
剛好2023年AI來臨
我就發現應該不用下車
所以就長線就一路抱到現在
當然很多人有時候回檔
就比如說7月好了
那7月在回檔的過程當中
也有人留言說
你說這個有信心高持股不下車
真的這樣看起來是不對的
你沒看到7月
跌了多少
那時候可能很多人對
明翰的頻道就會說你看我
害我本來賺錢的
現在都吐回去了
對 對 就真的會有
這樣的聲音跑出來
之前是開開心心
一跌就不開心了
對 我也覺得這個時間點
就是兩個問題
第一件事情
就是因為我連我
也不可能知道
6月22日當時就是最高點
7月要開始修正
是不可能有人知道
那有些人會說
他看到什麼
我在我之前也跟一些投資人講
你有時候你會跟我講說
其實
回過頭來6月22日
那個時候等於是
今年波段那個最高點
其實是有跡可循的
比如說他可能看到三個因素
他覺得當時是高點
我說如果你用這三個因素
去回推
你抱不到6月22日
因為很早之前就曾經出現過
因為這幾年真的漲的速度太快
出現的時候要跑
我只能跟你講
你很早就跑
你絕對不可能抱到6月22日
不可能抱到最高點
因為最高點之前
早就已經是瘋狂狀態
應該說
尤其是第二季
其實接近三個月時間
在狂漲的過程當中
如果你看到某個指標該退場
你就確實退場
我個人覺得
你應該在4月就會退場
因為後面五、六月是創歷史
從來沒見過的瘋狂途徑
所以然後最後你不可能在
已經創歷史新高
到底要高到哪裡的時候
突然在6月底的時候
突然警覺又全部下車
所以第一件事情就是
本來就不可能知道這個高點
第二就是壓回的過程當中
都已經壓回了
我也不知道最後會跌到
4萬點
甚至跌破4萬點
只能說會修正
因為技術面上半年漲太多
然後最後的關鍵點
就是我為什麼會去抱
因為我會覺得48,000點
我就不覺得是今年的高點
我總會覺得還會再上
那我能做的是什麼
就是沒有錯我的總
我的長線部位就是抱上抱下
但是有個好處就是我在
下來7月的過程當中
因為符合我的條件
所以我會拿我一些短線的
資金跟之前所剩的資金
在7月大家最恐慌
你自己回去查
反正黑K棒最長的時候
我一定都有我的買
我的進場買單
我就最喜歡買那個爆量黑K棒
技術面最慘的時候
因為我常常講了
信心最主要是建立在
我剛剛提到的營收、獲利一路創高
所以我就不覺得有問題
然後市場的拉回
也看不到任何理由
當然每天
這個等於說
報紙一定會告訴你
去槓桿
槓桿率過高
對 每天都有新的理由
但我們在節目我也常講
當你每天的理由都不同
就代表就是沒有理由
然後我要對比而言
你關稅
戰火什麼什麼..
那個就很明確
對
如果不是明確理由
每天都講不同
甚至之前有看到媒體說
今天的下跌理由我終於找到了
我就說那就表示是你瞎扯
因為全市場大家都在賣
但是大家都不知道
只有你知道
就知道這個根本絕對不是理由
所以我常常講就最後沒有
理由就是讓你重點你要把
長線的趨勢已經看得很明確
那拉回反而是很好的買點
至於你說中間高點應該要減碼
然後低點再加碼回來
我個人覺得這個理論上
我覺得回過頭來
我以前的特色就是
如果每次賠錢
我就會檢討一下
希望以後不要再發生
然後不斷調整成自己覺得
投資上最舒服的一個狀態
那我覺得目前的角度
我覺得蠻適合我自己
但不代表一定適合所有人
所以我分享來講
我是把概念告訴你說
不代表反彈上去不能減碼
只是你的要減碼的特色
兩個點你一定要自己先抓好
而且有一個很更重要問題
就是我以前遇到投資人
第一件事情是先沒有
那我跟他講要有
那他也沒關係
後來有了
但重點是到了
真的真的跌到90塊了
他又會說
明天搞不好更便宜
是心態很難克服
對 這心態很難克服
或者是說
最後沒跌
漲到105塊了
你應該追回來
你會覺得
搞不好明天就會拉回
會更便宜
最後我常常講的就是第一
該做的一定要做
第二就是不能給自己任何藉口
時間到
該操作該買賣的部分
一定要嚴格
我自己經過
自己的投資
加上後來法人訓練
最後再回到自己比較
我自己覺得現在
能夠輕鬆的投資
其實我覺得最後的關鍵點
就是紀律
我還是覺得紀律是最重要
因為每個人的策略
我的策略不代表適合你
或者說每個達人
都有不同的策略
可是我會覺得最後能夠成達人
每個人策略不同
但是一定有個共同點
就是他今天講到哪裡
他一定會按表操課
我覺得這才是最重要的
好就像前幾天有跟大家分享
連續三天都跟大家講
因為明年要交屋的關係
所以會把資產
從部分的債券型ETF挪到用
用資本利得配息的ETF上面
這裡面其實有很多的眉眉角角
可能一時之間沒有辦法
很完整的跟大家講
但大家已經
迫不及待的不停的私訊我
到底我配了哪幾檔
在前三天
大家可以回去聽Podcast
我裡面有唸到的那些ETF
我幾乎可能都會
先買個幾張放著
為什麼你要有一個
所謂的基本盤
在這個基本盤上
如果過幾天
像今天跌500多點
我成交的就比較多
那在這個基本盤下
又發生了回檔2,000點
你就不會覺得難過
你會覺得
你用一個好的
比你的成本
因為你一定會看到綠油油的
你現在建的第一筆
那時候一定綠油油的
你就可以往下去買
但是我必須強調一件事情
換到這樣子的商品上面
我的想法很簡單
債券確實是保本
這件事情它的特質
沒有任何的改變
當今天有一個
很大的下跌的時候
你會發現債券在那邊可能就是
零點幾%的一個波動而已
但換到這類型的商品
當然你會感覺到它整個
年化報酬率拉得很好
有可能賺價差
也可能息的年化報酬率
是超過10%
但是遇到回檔修正的時候
你的帳面波動肯定會變得很大
那為什麼會做這樣的轉換是
我明年要交屋
所以我現在到底明年
交屋的錢準備好了沒
答案就是在過去比較保守
注意風險
資產配置
股債配置之下
我把這筆錢已經準備好了
我可以承擔比較大的風險
來嘗試賺比較高
一點的報酬或是配息
我這些息都是資本利得配
所以我也可以免除掉我之前
非常擔心的所得稅的問題
好還有一個問題是
如果像明年、後年好了
如果這是一個長線投資
遇到真的股市是走
一個比較空頭的時候
也要記得
搞不好息就配不出來
因為他們叫資本利得來配
那他沒有資本利得
所以你可能也會面臨到
息有配不出來的問題
這些都要全部
通盤思考
因為我做的不是
一個下個月的規劃
我做的是一個可能3-5年
我要這樣做的計劃
所以這邊也呼應一下明翰
但我們回到最近
為什麼覺得局勢明朗
例如說像最新的新聞
輝達現在感覺上
又成為一個AI的主宰了
因為他開始做融資平台之外
他也宣布
他會注資
就是幫忙OpenAI這家公司
4.3兆台幣
相關的一些費用
當然中間一定會有條件
不是我們送人家錢這樣子
所以OpenAI雖然還在虧損
可是他的虧損幅度已經有些減小了
以及輝達看起來就是鐵了心
你給我不要當阿斗 你一定要起來
那另外是 Anthropic
就是做Claude這個語言模型的
它已經由虧轉盈了
我覺得這個這一個世代
我們知道在AI上面
發展最多就是
語言模型
然後賣算力
資料中心
所以這些新的公司
能夠得到注資
然後能夠在已經茁壯的
大企業下得到錢 然後
獲利體質也變好
我覺得它就是一個保障
它就是告訴你明年除了
原本的什麼科技七巨頭
它會有這種新創的軟體公司
語言模型公司
AI算力相關的
它明年也會茁壯
所以它是
一個一棒一棒接下去的狀態
至少我看到明年
甚至有人看到可能2028年
都覺得這樣的態勢
不太容易逆轉
對 讓我們
我覺得這個觀念
我們從幾個角度出發
第一個問題
就是大家應該這樣
企業在投資AI的腳步
包含剛剛提到
比如說他有融資平台
或者是投資OpenAI
其實結論而言就是我們
常常講的AI的資本支出
是 只是說今天錢是誰丟的
但我覺得不重要
反正就是
現在到底市場上這些大企業
到底對AI的投資的架構如何
是
那我的觀點
常常就會覺得
反正就我的
自己的理念來講
只要願意投錢
代表這個產業就是對的
當然在過程當中
常常因為剛好股市在修正
然後大家就會覺得
這不太對
這個風險很高
以後也不知道能不能回收回來
過一段時間又說
這個其實是對的
反正我覺得
你要先有個信念
就是如果對於這種
所謂的大企業的營運
你稍微有點理解
你就可以知道
真的是一個公司
尤其這麼大公司
這麼大的一個資本支出
都不是一個人說了就算
企業要花錢
不是你自己
像你自己要
買一個便當到底要買100還200塊
差不多就就掏錢的
公司今天要投1億還是2億
它其實中間的這個過程
其實比你想像的繁雜
非常非常多
那這樣的情況下
尤其是這麼大的企業
如果你今天就是老闆
當然可以決定
企業這麼大
你有很多的股東
你有很多的管理階層
那所以老實講
我不斷就是重申
你看一下法說會
魏哲家講的
今天能投這麼多錢
他就真的有這麼多的訂單
然後這個錢不是亂投的
這也不是他一個人決定的
這個後面的架構比
你想像要複雜很多
那大部分的現象就是
我會覺得這個論點
如果我們拉回到1年多前
2024年的時候
我覺得講這個論點相對來講
我覺得會比較適合
因為..
因為2023年有
AI開始出來
但是那個時候完全
都還沒有明顯架構
到2024年開始的特色就是等於說
這個輝達的這個伺服器
已經大量
出貨然後大家開始大量購買
那個時間點你會
一直在講說錢花那麼多
我不知道能不能賺得回來
那個還算合理
可是你從現從今年
尤其財報的角度無論
尤其是美股
我覺得比較明顯
因為我們台灣就是賣鏟子
所以根本不用講那麼多
反正他們願意投錢
我們就是賣鏟的
我們就是賺錢
所以我們從台灣的財報
我覺得沒有太大的參考意義
可是如果你回到美股的財報
你要記得那邊的人是他買鏟子
他到底挖出什麼
現在是大家正在爭論不休的
可你要記得一件事情
你不用去看他到底投了多少錢
或再研究他的自由現金流
自由現金流是什麼就是
公司的收入去減掉他的投資
然後現在就因為投資太多
他其實只有收到100塊 他投120塊
所以最後-20塊
然後大家很恐怖
可我就是說
你不要太糾結在
為什麼要投100塊
你要先去看他的100塊
現在等於說收入的100塊
跟前一段時間比是怎樣
你發現前一季只有70塊
再前一季只有20塊
他現在
就是因為投入之後
為什麼經過這兩年的投入之後
你會發現雲端業者的投入
真的是有點到瘋狂的階段
因為他會覺得
最一開始是怕
輸人家
是
因為大家因為大家都有概念
以後應該王者只有一個
搜尋引擎只有一個
然後社群平台只有一個
大家都想要搶當那個王者
是
幾乎不會有第二名
所以在等於說2年前
大家在投資的原因
是因為不想輸人
後來一開始的時候
如果正常來講
這種股東會剛開始也可以接受
可是如果股東會
就是真的出錢的人
我今天一開始
可以接受你這個故事
投資一、兩年
如果數字一直沒有進來
我覺得後面投資的
等於說大老闆也會害怕
你是講說
我們會輸人
一直輸人
那我錢一直砸
然後最後都沒有任何的回收
然後甚至公司已經都在虧損
那當然是玩不下去
可是這幾年
到每一季到包含剛剛
公布的四大雲端業的財報
它獲利很多都是創歷史新高
他也告訴你說
他們這兩年的投入
都已經開始回收了
但是我會覺得
大家耳朵通常在
必須把真的股價的走勢
看清一點點
那其實比較重要的
道理就是真的人家這兩
前面兩年辛苦耕耘
現在已經開始回收
那在回收過程當中
如果今天是出資人
就是股東
他要求要更大的投資
那我就可以接受
因為前兩年
你那時候是告訴我
這個畫大餅說
我們不要輸隔壁的
所以我現在必須投AI
那時候我只..
我是有點被
這個被壓著必須投
那我也只能說 好吧
我們只能賭賭看
因為我不想輸隔壁我先投
這兩年獲利已經衝出來
也告訴你確實有貢獻的
那這個時間點
你一定要告訴我說
這個時候你賺的錢
先不要拿回去
我們再把這個賺的錢再凹下去
因為每個月
每一季的回收都越來越大
這個時候先不要拿錢
賺的錢再壓下去
這個時候如果我是這些股東
我就很容易同意
現在慢慢的進入這個階段
所以你永遠會聽到
現在市場上的資本支出
不斷擴張
那當然
到最後會有個問題
就是我們前段講的
你收入去減掉你的支出
最大的問題來了
就是很多人其實為了要拼
其實他沒有收到那麼多錢
所以就會開始
有融資槓桿的問題
但是我老實講
我也不能講說
這個融資不要
完全不用管他
完全沒有風險
這也不能這麼說
槓桿如果真的拉高
確實有一定的風險
所以我還是要常常講
當然那個主要在美股
所以你在自己的個股投資
就要留意
如果今天他主要都是賺的錢
他就跟大家講
我們先不要分
我們就繼續投資
這都沒有問題
但是如果他一直拉高
槓桿一直拉高槓桿
那這個部分
我就覺得是另當別論
但目前就美股整體的重量級的
科技類股其實
都不太存在這個問題
因為結論為什麼
因為他們很有錢
所以他不需要很高的槓桿
或者是他們一缺錢
只要發個債
很低的利息就可以
募到很多的超額認購
結論來講
他們根本不缺錢
所以現在整體而言
如果真的要出事
系統性風險一定要大的倒
小的倒是不可能存在
就是有辦法造成系統性風險
所以目前的角度
只要這個大的維持這樣的營運
獲利能夠進來
他願意去續投
我覺得風險都不高
至於自己的投資的部分
是不是
這些中小型的
是不是拉高槓桿
有可能導致風險
我覺得這個
可能就要另外留意了
好
反正在產業上面
我們的共識一直都非常高
如果大家從第二季的季報
來看的話
為什麼最近像台光電
創歷史新高
或載板
這個欣興今天也創了歷史新高
南電應該也有
他們都會是
在產業認同上面高的
因為這個東西
我們講了比較多趟
可能今天我們反而花了一點
心思是跟大家講
交易的策略觀念
好所以目前想法沒有改變
目前想法沒有
我們也不會因為說
載板今天創歷史新高了
然後是不是太貴
我們沒有預設這個立場
因為它的產業共識
真的非常的高
但是像PCB
大家之前不是很喜歡
問什麼金居、金像電嗎
現在也慢慢上來
他們有比較多
是法人籌碼的問題
因為投信在之前
有的叫做被迫停損
有的可能他覺得短線上
上面套牢的賣壓太大了
他們先去做別支
可是以基本面上來說的話
都沒有問題
所以如果以第二季的季報來看
來檢視甚至檢視第三季跟
第四季的成長的話
我覺得PCB
大概是一個毋庸置疑
回檔的越深
大家應該越有
那個feel
去喜歡他們的
記憶體可能就剛剛有講到
它比較兩極
例如說我們都看到記憶體的
模組廠繳出嚇死人的財報
顆粒廠也有
可是好像就變得很集中
是南亞科獨佔鰲頭
會有一個這樣的現象
那這樣子我們要怎麼
知道這個族群叫不叫委屈
好 我們先講
我自己對這個市場我覺得
我把這個市場分成四個區塊
一個區塊
就是所謂的AI績優股
那AI績優股的定義也很容易
就是不是今年
應該說2024、2025年
過去兩年的獲利都很好
然後現在也都很好
這樣的我才叫做AI績優股
那比如說了
我常常講了
就這些個股其實
老實說這個名單列出來
也許就個二、三十檔之類
而且這些名單
其實從來都不會變
就比如說剛剛兆華
點名的這些PCB
是 其實你回頭去看
他們不是今年
不是今年獲利
去年就非常好
甚至2024年就已經很好
這兩年的這個獲利YoY
都是好幾十個不是
甚至倍數在增長
所以這些本來就叫做
AI績優股甚至
可能最近比較熱的川湖
你回去看
它真的不是今年好
是
它也2024年就已經營收
就是一路在創歷史
新高
而且我們上次聊過
它中間還有回檔相當多
對 它回檔
雖然股價跌了快半年
可是它的營收一直都在創高
所以我常常講
這種叫做AI績優股
這是第一類
第二類叫做黑馬股
對 所謂黑馬股就是有在變好
跟完全沒變好
但是未來也許有一些想法的
我覺得這個叫黑馬股
是
第三類很特別
就是記憶體
因為我會另外把他拉出一個類
因為他為什麼我會特別拉
因為你不能講他的數字不好
他數字好到炸
他數字應該這樣講
數字應該是
現在整個上市櫃最好
他絕對甚至
比這個AI績優股還好
因為他為什麼因為
它不像AI績優股已經第三年
它們是去年下半年開始
所以到現在可能也才一年多
所以它們還有一個
相對比較低的基期
所以一直到現在
它們的數字還是爆炸好
但是又很特別你說把
那他可以貴
如果今天他有吃到AI
我覺得他就是已經
算是很標準的AI股
因為他去年就已經開始轉強
不是今年甚至第二季才轉強
他是去年就轉強
可是我自己最起碼
就我的角度
我就沒辦法把它當做AI績優股
原因是因為
他們吃到的AI比重
確實是蠻低的
純粹是因為這
比如說這個美國、韓國三大廠
在做這個HBM
所以導致
消費性記憶體的產能不足
這故事我常常講
這故事是不會改變的
你去年聽到
前年聽到
到現在也不會因為
他們股價漲了好幾倍
代表他們就吃到AI
其實他們吃到AI的比例
然後當投資人常常問我說
誰誰誰他有一個什麼商品
這個跨入AI什麼什麼的
我說我常常講不是沒有
所以我只能說比例很低
絕對在個位數
甚至連5%都不到
老實說現在對他們
真正的幫助並不是太大
他們的完全的獲利來源
就是所謂的DDR4的報價
那但是有個好處
應該說好
回過頭來先了解架構之後
先看一下現在的狀況
結論就是現在的記憶體報價
在這個兩個月前它突破之後
現在確實在創歷史新高所以
整個記憶體的基本面
現在是強勁的
那但是
它目前來講有另外有
兩個比較弱勢的部分
第一個就是
大家應該也有感受了
現在的記憶體
不像以前的記憶體
以前的記憶體在漲的時候
你不管買什麼記憶體
從製造到模組到IC到通路
甚至封裝
只要記憶體封裝
五個族群大家一起飆
我覺得非常合理
因為當時記憶體在好的
這五大族群的營收獲利
都有往上走
現在的架構是什麼
這五大族群的獲利
營收也還在往上走
但是股價已經完全看不出來
他們營收獲利很好的狀況
沒錯 常常講
利多不反應
就像這個群聯
當時等於說法說會講得非常好
那甚至我們應該講
我講個故事就好
我們去
錄影的時候也有其他
專家在跟我講個笑話說那天
這個群聯出來的時候
然後有個分析師
甚至還一直堅持說他要講的
他就是認為很樂觀
隔天居然還這麼慘
我說那我不覺得
那個人是有問題
因為從基本面的角度
是真的很好
你不要因為開高走低
就說他有問題
這是我以前的論點
就像台積電這次講完之後
跌7%
不是他有問題
是市場的資金有問題
以後會還他公道
那這一次群聯也是說得很好
完全不是他的問題
也不是分析師的問題
現在市場的資金確實
很明顯的有一個警覺性
現在就是共識
市場的共識決定這樣
對
不是公司有問題
是共識現在就是這樣
公司也沒說謊
分析師也沒有錯
純粹是資金
就是反映這個樣子
而且現在有個架構
就是有剛剛提到五大族群
四大已經..
基本面很好
但是已經完全不反應
製造的部分就是所謂的
南亞科、華邦電、旺宏
甚至旺宏今天盤中還有
記者打電話來跟我說
為什麼旺宏這麼弱
對
那我的意思說
現在的架構的感受就是
現在台灣的記憶體
就只剩下一個南亞科
然後就是它有辦法創高
其他的現在利多就是往下殺
所有的
在操作記憶體的人
就是要嘛就是在
我剛剛講
如果你有記憶體
然後你不在南亞科的
就會感覺很不舒服
然後每天都在想
我是不是應該賣掉
我手上的某某某
換成南亞科
那確實這是一種糾結
但是我個人覺得
我先跟大家講結論
就是如果你今天是做
可能是操作短線的
我就跟大家講
事實就是如此
如果你要操作短線
就是買南亞科
因為這個族群就有點
類似我上一季在講的
這個所謂的被動元件
它是往上沒錯
但它不是沒有風險存在
所以記得就是順勢強勢操作
你應該買強者
不要去買落後的
不見得一定會補漲
那所以我剛剛提到
你就必須要直接買這個南亞科
那這重點在哪裡
就是你要觀察什麼
要記得AI跟
南亞科的關係其實非常低
幾乎可以
幾乎完全可以忽略
你要盯的是DDR4的報價
那我們一開始就跟大家講
因為現在DDR4的報價還在創高
所以最起碼我覺得
是一個安全的狀態
但是後續
如果DDR4的報價
漲勢也開始趨緩
我就覺得可能要有
一點點這個警覺心
我也一直提醒大家
你只要台灣買記憶體的
不要聽故事
那個網路開啟
每天都有報價3次
多看報價
少看故事
對投資反而比較有幫助
沒有錯
而且如果你不擅長這個族群
我們就
看報價也聽故事
不用硬操作
因為之前有人留言跟我說
兆華你可以挺一下記憶體
每次都說你不擅長
對
我只是在提供一個平台
就是我每天幾乎都會請我的
來賓幫大家分享記憶體
因為我知道很多散戶朋友喜歡
但是我不擅長就是我不擅長
我也有這樣的模板
我有擅長其他的東西 所以
這個真的是很看個人
但我必須承認剛剛講到的
基本面沒有問題的情況下
什麼東西叫做市場的共識
就是技術面跟籌碼面
因為法人不青睞
只有一個分析師青睞沒用
你投信不買
外資在倒貨
所以你今天市場共識是
我知道你很好
可是我現在對你沒興趣
它就會造成
資金一直外流
那技術面的好處是什麼
技術面為什麼講說像載板
當時候市場有共識
它回也回不深
彈又彈最快
好 你說
以基本面來看
它不是最厲害的那一個
可是產業前瞻是
它是缺口會越來越大的那一個
技術面它是最強勢的那一個
技術面的強勢
它就容易把市場的共識
凝聚回來
代表說後面那隻手
它不想讓它跌太深
沒有人棄守它
所以共識這個事情
是我們要理解的
剛剛講說誰都有可能錯
我們有一個結論
叫做市場永遠是對的
對 沒錯
我們講錯殺
錯殺的意思是之後會還公道的
在現階段你不能說這個
共識它的問題在哪裡
你只能說你對這件事情
有沒有信念
好 我剛一直在看我的
這個今天的交割款
就是買股票
真的是一個很好的shopping
我也想給明翰看我
支持他們家的商品
前東家 對 成交100塊
所以就是接下來如果再跌的話
我還會持續的
我的策略就是如此
我不是追強勢者
剛剛講到的
要強勢你就選盤面上
現在各族群裡面的領頭羊
甚至你喜歡川湖
你喜歡台光電
它在形態上面
你喜歡欣興、南電
它都沒有問題
是追強的好選擇
但是如果你喜歡
像兆華這樣子的話
那遇到大的回檔
切記不要害怕
而是知道是機會
跟明翰一樣
明翰也是看到
跌2,000多點那一天
他有發文
看得出來很開心這樣好
那今天我們這一集
就先到這邊了
也呼籲大家
就先放棄明翰的臉書
這個平台
希望以後如果剩下
一個社群平台
不是剩下臉書
剩別的真的是
讓我們極度的困擾
那就跟各位股惑仔們說拜拜
拜拜